prácticamente todos los líderes de los
países europeos se encuentran en
moldavia en una reunión de la comunidad
política europea un foro entre países de
la Unión Europea y también países
candidatos o potencialmente candidatos a
entrar dentro de la Unión Europea para
abordar los desafíos comunes del
continente entre ellos la guerra en
Ucrania precisamente el presidente
ucraniano Vladimir zelensky ha acudido a
la cita en que ha asegurado a su llegada
en que la guerra terminará cuando Rusia
abandone el territorio ucraniano y
también ha argumentado que Ucrania está
preparada para entrar en la otan en una
respuesta así al secretario general de
la alianza James stoltenberg quien
aseguró ayer que se le deben ofrecer
garantías de seguridad al país una vez
haya terminado la guerra la reunión de
la comunidad política europea se trata
de un foro ideado por el presidente
francés Emmanuel
porque se considera que puede ser una
oportunidad para atender puentes en todo
el continente y así lo aseguró ayer en
una aplaudido discurso Emanuel macron en
que habló de la importancia de tender
puentes ella alianzas entre el este y el
oeste del continente aun así la reunión
se encuentra también en a la expectativa
de las tensiones que ahora mismo hay
entre kosovo y Serbia especialmente en
el norte de kosovo todo el mundo estará
pendiente porque los líderes de ambos
países también están presentes en este
encuentro con el objetivo de que también
se pueda rebajar la tensión